نحن أسرع الأمراض في
العالم ، هل يمكنك مواكبة هذه القصة الكبيرة العظيمة التي
تم تحقيقها بواسطة Geico ،
نعتقد أن Geico يمكن أن يوفر لك 15 ٪ أو
أكثر من التأمين على السيارات ،
مرحبًا MA ، أنا مثلي ، أتخيل أننا
المستقبل الذي جمعنا فيه بين الشعب الهنغاري التقليدي
الرقص بربطات وإيقاعات الرقص الحديثة
بدأنا الرقص منذ حوالي 20
عامًا ،
أكوا موسى هو أحد أصدقائي المقربين
نشأنا معًا وماتي هو
أخي الأصغر ، لذلك لا يمكننا تجنب
بعضنا البعض ، تعلمنا أن الرقص الشعبي الهنغاري
هو  ليس فقط من غرفة التدريب
ولكننا أجرينا أبحاثًا
حصل الرقص الشعبي المجري على تسجيلات مؤرشفة
كبيرة وتعلمنا الرقص منهم أحد
أكبر المؤثرين لها هو مايكل
فلاتلي والطريقة التي قام بها زملائه في الفريق الأيرلندي
يرقص المشهور عالميًا بـ 35 نقرة
في ثانية واحدة نحن  هم راقصون شعبيون هنغاريون ،
نستخدم أقدامنا ويدنا بدلاً من أن
نبدأ بالأساسيات وبعد ذلك
يمكنك بناء أسلوبك الخاص ، فنحن بحاجة إلى
الكثير من التدريب لهذا الأمر المشترك ، فنحن نقوم به
20 ساعة في الأسبوع في 20  14 لقد سجلنا رقمًا قياسيًا عالميًا
نحتفظ به 3937 مرة في
دقيقتين ،
كان أحمد هو الأسرع منا ، فقد قام بـ 41
صفعة وضرب في ثانية واحدة ، لذا
أصيبت أيدينا بعد الكثير من الحرارة ،
نعم ، نود أن نجعل من
الهنغاريين قومًا  الثقافة أكثر شيوعًا في
جميع أنحاء العالم ،
نتحمل مسؤولية كبيرة حول كيفية استمرارنا
والاستمرار أو التراث ،
نتخيل حياتك بالرقص ونتخيل
مستقبلنا مع بقرة غنية
[موسيقى]